bernard i'm so interested to hear your
take on this you
hinted at it in this last segment
it's this idea that there is a
there's a there's a list in a sense of
there's like a catalog
of biometric correlates
to phenom phenomenological states of
experience
i really like this a lot and actually i
think
the more that we collectively invest
into science
identifying these biomarkers and
especially at the
building better tools to understand the
biometrics
everything from eeg and fmri to ekg
to microbiome so all over and then
taking that readout and then being able
to provide
like a artificial general intelligence
health corpus
be able to or ai coach can just you know
provide these
in these feedbacks these insights into
you know you your
heart rate variability is super
low right now you are stressed and like
what's the what's the interaction that
you know maybe going to the pool or
going in a walk right or whatever it may
be doing some motion
um so how do you you mentioned this
earlier about this idea that like
if we had the biometric correlate of
your
phenomenological state we could in a
sense have like
a telescopic or microscopic idea of what
that is so
tell us about your your reasoning
process around that
well i mentioned earlier i think matter
is just what inner experience looks like
from a perspective from across a
dissociative boundary and i think the
dissociative boundary
that that defines us as individuals
uh presents itself in perception as the
skin the eyes or
our sensory organs this this is the
boundary of
the this dissociative process in
universal mind that we call ourselves
so if matter is that
what is what experience looks like from
across a dissociative boundary then the
matter of the brain is no exception
neither is the matter of the rest of the
universe but let's talk about the brain
if brain activity is what our normal
individual mentation
looks like from across a perspective of
course there will be correlations there
will be lots of correlations
i would go further and say and suggest
that
we could even come up with interventions
in our
patterns of brain activity that could
lead us to certain
in desirable inner states
we know that psychoactive substances
from alcohol to psychedelics
they intervene with the matter in our
brain
and they lead us to other experiential
states i would say that
the psychedelic the alcohol or the scalp
of a neurosurgeon when he's digging into
your brain
this is all material therefore these two
are images of transpersonal conscious
processes the scalpel is what a
transpersonal conscious process looks
like
and it goes across your dissociative
boundary interferes with your dissociate
dissociated
individual experiential states uh what
it looks like is a scalpel cutting in
your brain
or a pill being digested and flooding
your brain with a psychoactive substance
that one mental process influences
another
is trivial our emotions influence our
thoughts they are different but they
influence one another
so by the same token a scalpel or drug
can influence our inner states
both our images our brain and that scalp
when the drug
are images of mental processes so
if we can decode the neuro correlates of
meta consciousness or metacognitive
awareness which
which is what i think they are we can
even
find ways to intervene into our brain
activity and
force desirable experiential states by
disrupting ordinary brain activity
in just the right way i think it is
possible to develop this technology and
i would look forward to using it
yes yes oh okay this
this uh this bits gonna it's getting
very interesting so
i loved the focus there on especially on
entheogens and i love that word because
it's about unleashing the divine within
um and it's without a doubt that
there is a super highly correlative
experience experiment with uh taking a
uh substance that late an antiogen and
then
having a psychoactive experience that in
a sense um
could incrementally awaken
and enlighten and so this is where i
want to take this segment now
um ultimately we're we're talking about
this idea of some sort of like
an artificial general intelligence
that's constantly taking in all the
sensor data like you have
like today we have jets that have
hundreds of sensors that constantly
monitor everything but like what
our body goes to the doctor one time a
year it's a joke
so the so the idea is that if if we're
constantly analyzing that stream of
sensor data from our body
and then we gave this idea earlier that
there's even something as simple as an
intervention for
for for stress maybe you go out walk on
a walk etc
but there's even deeper interventions
which you were
hinting at the idea that could it be
possible
to have a deeper understanding of a
correlate of specifically enlightenment
or
awakening something that is so
causeless joy and imperturbable peace
that is the
essence of what it would be across brain
across
heart across gut and then and then do
our best to nudge
our society in that direction how does
that resonate
i don't see any fundamental reason why
that shouldn't
be possible i could imagine
that under different circumstances it
could be impossible you could speculate
that maybe
our brain activity is not the complete
image of what's happening in our mind
it's a partial image
so by intervening in it you're not
intervening in a large segment that may
be relevant so you could speculate about
that
i don't see a reason to think that
i think measurable brain activity
at least measurable in principle there
is activity in the deeper areas of the
brain that today
is very hard to measure with proper
spatial and
temporal resolution but i'm talking
about what is possible in principle
um i think we can in principle measure
everything
that plays a role in our mental states
and
it should be possible if we cared to
invest and
if he cares to develop the technology
and do the research necessary
to stimulate uh mental states that are
conducive to enlightenment or which may
be
our enlightenment we know anecdotally
that
many a psychedelic traveler traveler
has maybe by sheer luck or chance
arrived at a mental state that they
described as
unmistakingly enlightened
you can't do that every time you can't
choose that that's where it's going to
take you psychedelic trips are
very noisy unpredictable they they mix
profound truths
with with profound delusions so it's
very hard to make sense of that we don't
have any control of that
but if we could develop a technology to
control it better at the right
resolution i don't see
any reason why this shouldn't be
possible yeah
yeah there's and that's
this idea of one these interventions
on the awakening or enlightenment
trajectory is
one sort of idea in in a sense they're
they're they're interconnected with
these other ones but just some general
other ones where like
okay you're having you know some back
pain that we're getting an idea about
like get up and go on that walk or go
swim
um another idea okay we're sensing some
you know some ghrelin you
you you you're having this active
sensation happen
for you to want to eat and so but you
want to fast today
so what is the intervention that could
happen today to help you
um fast and so what's your north star if
your if your idea is that you want to
become
a deeper philosopher of mind or if you
want to become a better artist or
scientist or
spiritual leader whatever you want to
become what are those
interventions that can help you achieve
that north star yeah
there is a technology we call it a
transcranial magnetic stimulation
the name is a little bit misleading
because it may be the opposite of
stimulation it may actually
dampen down brain activity it has
beautiful spatial resolution it's
basically an electromagnetic beam that
goes across your skull
and messes up with the activity of your
neurons in
in the desired way and that's very
promising the problem is that it doesn't
have
much penetration so you can activate
or deactivate superficial areas of the
neocortex but you can't go
much deeper but that's an avenue of of
r d research and development that we
could pursue to achieve exactly what you
what you're
hinting at yeah that's that's a
crucial one and uh we've heard the
analogies of it being like uh
like a a stadium or an arena and like
you're just like outside the stadium or
the arena trying to like
understand what's happening on the field
and just by like the bear
the bear noise on the yeah yeah fair
analysis
and the tools that's why it's so
important to build better tools because
the better
tools enable more edge pushing
to happen all right
and it does seem like it's slowly going
in the direction of
an idea of like a service to self like a
more of a self dealing ego driven
uh mentality of just survival and
reproduction
um towards something that is more of an
enlightened
awakened service to other consciousness
do you feel that
i in my optimistic moments yeah
the rest of the time you know
we we've taken such an individualistic
turn after the 60s especially in the 80s
and from then onwards
um that it's hard sometimes to
to stay uh positive but there are some
bright
lights there are things happening today
that would be unthinkable
uh not a long time ago um for instance
because of the the benign influence of
non-dualism in the west
which picked up steam really this
century
uh it started already back in the new
age movement new thought but it really
picked up steen
this century we now have a language
to talk about transpersonal mental
states
non-duo states before we didn't even
have
the language the course that's so yeah
the lexicon the two
the conceptual tool set to even talk
about that to say
something coherent about it and and that
has led to some disasters i mean
there was a book written about um famous
western philosopher
arthur schopenhauer there's a book
written about him in 1994
by uh supposedly expert
on his writings and philosophy and this
guy had the temerity of
criticized schopenhauer but in doing
that criticism
the only thing he revealed was his utter
inability to comprehend schopenhauer's
non-dual
ideas his non-dual philosophy and why
did that happen because
you know i'm being kind to this
professor now because in 1994 we didn't
have the language the conceptual tool
set
to even not only to understand but to
talk about what that guy was
trying to hint at he had to develop his
own language which
in a way led to disaster because nobody
really understood what he was talking
about
but now we can understand now i can
write a book talking about these things
and and people share the dictionary with
me they know what i'm
hinting at so that's very optimistic
that's a good sign that things are going
the right way i try to remember this
every day
yeah yeah i i'm so happy you brought
that up the more
that we drive a novel lexicon
that is very
clearly the essence of where our north
star is on our civilizational and
individual trajectories
that's when it makes it more and more
clear for us to share that
corpus like you were indicating that's
so so critical and share that vision